[Music]
one boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we have an exciting episode
tonight we are going to be talking about
mysticism and we have a great guest to
feature for that topic Jessica Ann Hut
Welker
thanks for coming on the show and
joining us really appreciate it yes it's
gonna be a lot of fun we have a lot to
unpack there's a tremendous amount of
information around the subject and it is
important to make it relatable and it's
a lot of its most of you know subjective
for each individual so alright so let's
start first by talking about this which
is nuts because I think a lot of people
are starting to see that there's being a
big transition of people away from
corporate America following their sole
purpose and so let's let's at least
start with this you know 20 years in
corporate America it's it's a very long
time and there's you know there's some
there's good in that but there's more in
the sole purpose so let's talk about the
transition what led you to that point
yeah it really kind of started when my
mother passed away I was 24 and she had
pancreatic cancer and the last seven
weeks of her life I was with her taking
care of her every day helping out around
the house
and the day that she finally crossed
over and went back she her spirit came
to me and the first time she came to she
came to me twice that day and I heard
her she went Jessie Jessie and I was so
exhausted that I fell asleep and then
later that night she came a second time
Jessie Jessie and I was too scared to
open my eyes this thing that I wanted so
much and I reflected on that moment so
many times I just really really wish I
could have seen her had that closure had
that confirmation and and I didn't I was
too scared and it is there's two regrets
in my life and that is one of them I
have not regretted anything else but
that I wasn't brave enough to open my
eyes and what's been really remarkable
is that in those moments of like
greatest pain and deepest grief are the
catalysts for me of what's become my
greatest gift and joy so by being so
scared I'm not having that bravery
pushed me to be brave and so much of my
life that got me to this moment that I'm
at now so when she passed
I had nothing my car I'd died it have a
place to live I didn't have a job and
nothing and one of my uncle's was in
Florida and said hey it's coming I'm
working for he's looking for someone you
can come live with me right into work
with me he was a godsend truly so I'll
make out my feet but I remember being at
his place in my bed sobbing because I
was like I know I'm meant to do
something more and I remember praying at
the time to God being like please just
tell me why I'm here why I'm here I'm
meant to be doing so I can spend my life
doing it instead of spend my life trying
to find it and and I really didn't get
that answer until a couple of months ago
so it was um you know 12 12 years so
there's a lot of steps I can p-pretty in
depth with the whole story but that's it
really started all along I just I felt
it you know we get those moments where
we just feel so there's that friction in
us you know I'm doing this thing that
I'm told I should be doing and and I
should be happy and I remember there was
a point where I was really dissatisfied
in my job and my father was like you get
to travel wherever you want you're
getting paid really really well
you've got great benefits which is so
important for our parents you know to
have like good benefits and all that I
love my dad so much for that and I was
like but I'm not happy I'm not fulfilled
and and there's and it just gets worse
it doesn't get easier just for me at
least I got you know very very
uncomfortable very painful and what
really really changed the game there are
two things so when my mother passed we
had all right she had a baby there was
one half my little brother Griffin half
brother and I was going through
corporate America living my life
traveling around really focused on
throwing my passion into a vehicle there
was not not the vehicle I was meant to
be in so it's like here's a Fiat I'm
gonna try to soup it up as best I can
you know throw and all these extra you
know bells and whistles to feel
passionate about it but that wasn't the
vehicle and so Griffin he was 13 fast
forward and I was in California I was on
a sales call and I got the call that he
had been in an accident and he actually
passed away and it bedrocks our whole
family it was just a creator like balm
you know it's like already we've barely
gone through my mother passing away and
then to have our beloved Griffin gone to
was just so painful and so her her
passing and then Griffin's really were
bookends into this chapter of my life in
the seeking thing and then it really
woke me up and shifted my whole life and
I was like why am i in a job that is not
fulfilling for me that I'm not
passionate about
that isn't why I'm here and at the
expense of not doing what I'm doing I
missed out on spending time with my
little brother and my family I chose
that I own that I chose that and I
missed out so talk about fear of missing
out is like fear of not living why we're
here and that that again in those deep
pain and grief you know leads to our
greatest joy so I really had to I really
didn't dig in deep and there was this
one night on the anniversary today's my
mother's birthday by the way so I'm just
so honored to be kind of just really
honoring her but January 31st is the day
that she passed and a year ago I tried a
new technique because I had a really
challenging relationship with her
growing up and I was like you know what
she did the best she could and if she
could have done it differently she would
have from advice from a really beautiful
woman and and then the middle the night
I woke up and I felt all this
information coming through me and I
grabbed a notebook and a pen I just
started writing and writing writing and
just all these things poured out pours
through me and I'm a writer but I'm not
a imaginative writer and there's just
all these different perspectives of
things that have happened and in the
world and everything like that and that
started this whole journey and and I I
woke up that morning I was like I think
I'm weak I'm gonna be done with my
career at the end of this month and I'm
like this is the only career I've ever
known but I knew that there was
something here and I just started
channeling and and I did at the end of
the month I said goodbye to that career
I had totally changed my life so much
and shocks shocked this industry that
was very very well known and I had
really built beautiful connections to
and I have a lot of love for them
but I was on this mission and I was like
if I'm here for something greater I'm
gonna do it there's two things there
that really stick out for I think a lot
of people there is a lot of
psychological distress that people go
through and they're live some sort of
traumas that occur to them
mother father passing brother assist
they're passing some sort of a divorce
or a relocation or something massive in
their lives shifts mom little brother
there's two big ones for you and then
there is also this sort of pressure that
we get from the assistance of social and
political and economic machinery of
civilization that pushes people in many
ways against their sole purpose and
vectors them into positions of serving a
mission that they don't subscribe to
because they need to get a paycheck to
pay for their roof and their food and
their living so those are kind of the
two things that really stick out I can
curious how many people follow a have
had a similar sort of transition and I
wonder how we can get people to
potentially understand their soul their
divine purpose here on earth prior to a
insanely catastrophic sort of
realization that that they in time time
you know some people comes at certain
times that's fine but it's just
something about that transition that
you're describing now that so many other
people either go through or are going to
go through yeah and we've spoken about
that before and when you know your your
soul has a purpose and it's going to do
it so there is gonna be this push-pull
and things are gonna start showing up in
your life that might seem kind of cosmic
or devastating to you but it's more
about yours in my opinion your soul is
trying to redirect course to get to you
to being why you're here and living that
life so the people are like oh my god I
just got fired from a job oh my god I
just lost a big promotion
my god I you know I'm this relationship
ended oh my god my car died you know
like all these things that like we take
on as we're like nuisances or
inconveniences or something much much
more devastating in our life if we were
to shift the Kaleidoscope and maybe look
at it through a different lens that
maybe this is actually our soul
redirecting course for us because we're
here and we're going like this and
whether we like it or not our soul like
it wants to honor that you know this is
why we were here
we just we forget that's one of the
conditions of coming into this earth is
we forget who we are we forget our soul
we forget what we're connected to we
forget that we're connected you know
that we have these soul families all
these beautiful beautiful things that
you know there are people like Marianne
Williamson and like all these incredible
people that are in touch and in tune and
tapped in and from a young age or an
older age we have these moments of
activation really it's activating it's I
think it's an awakening that's more like
we're being activated and we like
remember like oh or will at least
remembering enough to to move and shift
and change and so that that's really
what's happening for me the last four or
five months so activations can sometimes
never happen you can go from zero to 80
and be off your sole purpose the entire
time I do not believe that you will
leave this plane of existence on earth
without having accomplished what you
came here to do so when you're passing
away when you're 80 and then you feel
all of the regret around not not doing
that thing at 20 or at 40 or at 60 or
whatever that that sort of feeling those
could have been your those sole purposes
so you would have at least had the
feeling by the time you're passing that
those things and maybe your sole purpose
of that life was to show what it's like
to not live your purpose correct okay so
in that way you're an example for
potentially your family for other people
around you yet okay so you started
tapping into this so let's let's
continue talking about it now the last
couple of months for you you started
talking about the soul family's our
purpose here on earth
so let's start let's start unpacking
that a little bit more so the sort of
interconnectedness of everything in this
just yet continue rolling where you were
going because I want to I want to see
how you how you how you choose to unpack
the complexity of the last couple of
months for you because it's been a it's
been a crazy period of time for you it
has and I'm actually like the happiest
and most joyful I've been in my life and
I'm so grateful for everyone that's come
into it and but what it's what it really
took everybody is millions of leaps of
faith over and over again and it really
started to rewind the clock just a
little bit there was a day where I was
like I felt like I was so not in control
of my happiness even though we are right
we everything that we have that we
create is our creation but I just felt
so out of control I felt like my my
happiness was tied to my job was tied to
my boss was tied to my clients was tied
to all these other people were not my
own and so I really wanted to shake
myself up enough to realize that I'm
actually in the driver's seat in a way
that I am in control of my my happiness
and my destiny and so I decided to go
skydiving I was like was the craziest
craziest thing I can do to really
illuminate it for me and I figured if I
could jump out of a plane at 13,000 feet
and land that I could do anything and so
I decided what more I was going to do it
I didn't tell anybody because what
happens when you tell people something
crazy they try to talk you out of it
right and so I went and I had a wait a
few hours before I could board the plane
and I could have backed out at any time
but I was jumping with Bill who had been
alive for who have been jumping for 35
years so I was like okay like there's
anyone I want on my back it's Bill and
so we're at the edge of the plane the
doors open we're at 13,000 feet it's my
turn to jump and he cannot push me out
of the plane I have to choose take the
leap and so I'm at the edge of the plane
this is like the sliding door moments
you know where your whole life will go
into different directions and so I'm I'm
at the edge of the plane skies in front
of me and I was like am I going to
chicken out and sit back and keep living
my life the way I have been or am I
going to take the leap and even though I
don't know what's on the other side it
has to be better than this and so I left
I left and it was the most peaceful
thing that I've done in my life and when
I landed and very gracefully stepped out
of my gear I realized that the single
most important lesson I've learned in my
life is that the fear of doing it was
greater than actually doing it and I've
shared that story with thousands and
thousands of people since then but I
kept expanding and going outside my
comfort zone because that's where
everything is that we want is outside of
our comfort zone was about willing to be
brave to take those leaps again and
again and again and so where I am right
now as a reflection of a million of
leaps of faith that I've taken so so
four months ago is in Mexico at a
retreat on the way to the four months
ago Mexico retreat you as you were
speaking about fear and taking leaps of
faith and going to what's on the other
side yeah that in in my very you know
interestingly mathematical scientific
sort of understanding of things it just
looked like to me this funny graph over
time that fear you know here's your
decision that you're making fear right
raises raises raising panic panic even
it's that I and then as soon as you do
it it's way down here there's like no
fear it's only like enjoyment over time
and then by the time you get to like the
accomplishing that task you realize that
all the wisdom you gain from doing that
was so worth it so I'm just really happy
that that example is one of the most
profound in your life I personally felt
a very similar way on skydiving and just
overall in general on a lot of the
activities you know this upcoming TEDx
talk and just in general like hosting
events in front of
thousands even of people that eventually
you just do it because you know that
what's on the other side is bliss its
meaning it's a responsibility if makes
you feel incredible and not doing it is
not as living life to its fullest
well you're built yes all of that and
I'm so excited for you and everything
you've accomplished and well it's such
an honor to be in your life to
experience that but it it's like I feel
like the bravery is a muscle really it's
like you're working out you're you're
you're testing your inner strength you
know your ability to go beyond and so
then what would have seemed like a
skydive is really just hopping off a
chair you know like because we keep
growing and growing expanding so for me
to be like you've been like let's do
this live and I'm like uh but I've done
enough leaps that I'm like okay yeah
that's a good that's a good quick point
you know in this in the show right there
it's just take that leap yes and send
the fear and get to what's on the other
side because it will drive you to
feeling incredible so okay Mexico four
months ago
continue almost almost so if that brings
a really great point is that something
they did channel there was like if you
had any idea it was on the other side of
your fear any idea what was waiting for
you you would drop everything and run as
hard as you can toward it yep everything
is on the other side of your fear and
and I and that that was a message that
came very clearly through in my writing
and so I Ron I liked okay okay fine if
you're gonna say that then then the
question for me then becomes how do you
inspire more people to get to what's on
the other side of their fear that would
be my essence that would be something
that I would care about a lot to try on
people with well it's like I mean
what will it cost you if you do it and
what will it cost you if you don't do it
there you go it's a good way to put it
and for most people if you at least
write out the pros and cons what will it
cost you if you don't do it versus you
do do it you know don't do it you're
like safety comfort I'm sure and you
know I'm certain t and then on the on
the fear it's like uncertainty unsay not
safe unknown and then the interesting
thing is you know you can you can bias
your own pro and con list because on the
per on the on the pro list could be you
know self-actualization transcending
fear you know love of that activity you
know moving forward with my life with
abundance and you know versus the other
side you know so you can buy your own
list but I like I like you know where we
went with that can we close that out and
go on that was good that was really good
alright so rewind to May and I was in
Mexico and I had I made a huge huge
decision in my life where I was I
decided to choose myself over being in a
relationship with someone that wasn't
bring out my best and highest purpose
and joy and it was a again it's one of
those sliding door moments where you
kind of I like I made the decision and I
was like there's no going back
like the I love the no going backs is
like just keep on moving yep you know
and it's not to say like it's not about
him it's about me choosing like I
reached a point again as us being
creators of our lives
I was so pushed over the edge I was like
how the f is this my life like if I'm a
creator this is the life I've created
I'm like tap out I'm done
scrap this I'm doing it all over I'm
going to do it differently and what was
really amazing is that I didn't know
this but I was like kind of building
these little Domino's like I had this
whole beautiful design and then it was
just having a hit that first domino over
which was choosing myself and when I did
that then like the universe was like
yeah let's go for I know
took me so again there was a moment of
fear again of being maybe alone or that
maybe that this is the right choice for
me would to be in this position maybe
I'm making the wrong choice by going off
but like you said it was that first
domino and I just I really love that
connecting that to the first part of
what we were talking about because you
didn't make a choice and it did end up
you know being something that took you
on this amazing ride I was just really
enjoying playing that that out yeah it's
just it's great to know okay so but you
know and this actually brings up a good
point for me I think for a lot of women
you know we're intuitive we're all
everyone's intuitive okay it's just that
women tend to have a deeper sense of
intuition mothers intuition whatever you
want to call it and but we've been
taught to really kind of shut that down
like you know I'm feeling this way no no
it's not this it's a dot and you're like
okay and if someone speaks with enough
authority at least for me if someone
speaks with enough authority and
confidence chances are they're gonna
override my inner compass because I was
so cultivating it so when I was in that
relationship he was telling me these
things that felt like absolute truths
for him and even though I didn't feel it
I was like well maybe he knows better
maybe I just don't have all the pieces
yet maybe I just need this you know work
it out a little bit more but what it
really really was was like that was his
truth and that is totally fine and that
is not my truth this is my truth and
that's totally fine too so there's
something really really interesting
about I really encourage women that like
if he needs happen in tune in you're
like this doesn't feel right to me it
actually doesn't feel right and you
should you know make the change of
whatever it is in your life it's either
a [ __ ] you or he'll know exactly like at
all no so like I yes that's right and
and that's also interesting because it's
binary in that sense it's intuition
really binary or is there some gray area
in intuition as well I you know I guess
it comes down to what you're going to
choose to believe and so for me with my
intuition a lot of times I would
and there were a lot of times I
questioned everything and it really came
down to this moment about a month ago
where I was like okay am I going to
second-guess and question and doubt
everything that comes in or am I going
to just choose say decide that what
comes through is my truth and that's
okay run with it and that was another
big defining thing for me because once I
did that then things started really
really moving very quickly and so what
were the Domino's then the Domino's were
being in Mexico
it being introduced to a sacred plant
medicine called San Pedro and being
being told it's a heart opener and and I
remember experiencing it and I was just
so blessed out and it was so heart
opening and then I found I was like man
I so love to go to Ecuador for a month
and wear this girlfriend of mine have
been and experience this with her shaman
and then literally two days later my
work my boss called me was and was like
you know your job is no longer there you
know my position had been taken away my
role and there was like a little bit of
my ego that was upset and then like the
99% of me was like yes the universe is
like hurting me like there's been
calling me so I booked a one-way ticket
to Ecuador and put everything in storage
and and went down there and really
immerse myself in that really beautiful
platanus and and again like those leaps
of faith that you know just even
synchronistic synchronicities are just a
balance they're everywhere and I
manifested everything in manifested
meeting I manifested being here right
now and and so much of it came from
trusting myself being willing to go to
the deepest depths that I could healing
so much I was working with multiple
modalities at the same time in Ecuador
which was just one on its own would have
been amazing but the the multiple ones
they did together were a rocket fuel and
it just I remember who I am
I remember where I'm from I remember why
I'm here while my purpose is I I
reconnect like really really activating
my gift I reunited with my mother and my
like I was able to channel them and such
beautiful ways and for me to be a mystic
and into channel and to help people and
to provide them the just home so many
answers for what drives them what keeps
them up at night makes them desperate in
the day what makes them striving and
searching for all these things it's like
it's you know they're seeking out bits
like what if we try to pull it down and
gave you some different insight from
people that love you from the universe
that absolutely believes in you from
your higher self from your soul like all
those things so I feel so honored and
privileged and also that that that
channeling ability did not wake up in me
until my mother had passed away and I
didn't know that until my little brother
until I channeled him a couple weeks ago
and he reminded me of that so it's just
it's a hugely beautiful beautiful story
about the power of love and what our
family members are willing to do for us
so that we go and do what we're here to
do on our path ok so we have a couple of
these dominoes or are all rollin and
plant a sacred plant medicine of San
Pedro and from Mexico to Ecuador then to
California so so let's talk about what
you've now been tuning into what you've
been feeling what you've been
experiencing you've been using this
we're channeling let's explain what that
is yes so if you think about driving in
the car and you've got the FM radio on
you're trying to find a station and
you're doing the tuning so you're tuning
along it was like that you know like you
you find these different stations where
you can kind of get a clear signal
and that's how it is in my understanding
for me is that if you think about I I
believe that it's like I'm a transmitter
so it's like there's all these signals
going on in the universe and I'm gonna
tuned in on a certain level and then and
then I can get those signals down and
then I can speak it or I can write it or
I can embody it you know whatever it is
and so I didn't realize that how it
started until Griffin reminded me a
couple weeks ago was that when he was
little again he was 1 and a half of my
mother passed and a psychic had told me
that when he looked into my eyes he
would see my mother so ever since he was
little I pull him up on my lap and I
would really try to feel my mother as I
was speaking to him and saying like how
proud I am of you and how amazing you
are what a beautiful boy you are in such
a beautiful heart and all these things
and it was that was me starting to
activate that channel was by doing that
with him and then and then several years
later I was using with a pendulum which
is a divination tool I was I was doing
that and then years later that's when I
had the they wake up MoMA in the middle
the night and writing and writing and
writing you know so it just it form took
on different forms and different depths
and levels over time all right so let's
stick with the transmitter analogy so
you are taking in what signal through
you what is the signals the signal the
all that is is that the kind of the
fabric of existence everything in our
three-dimensional reality plus what's
outside of the three-dimensional reality
yeah so from my understanding right now
because I'm you know ramping it up quite
a bit I can channel well it depends on
who wants to come through one so there's
there are times where I open my laptop
I'll take a few deep breaths you know
and then it shifts and I just feel this
information that comes through my head
and I just
writing and so that could be an angel
that could be my mother that could be
prime creator that could be Divine
Feminine that could be my dog Sparky I
don't know why I guess he suddenly wants
to be here right now my of my former dog
you know but but what I love to be able
to offer to people is that I'm like so
what is your intention was your question
and they'll share with me what they've
what they're going through right now and
and then if it's a loved one they can
still be alive and their spirit could
come through like your mother could come
come through with something that she
wants to share and she has a lot of
things that she likes to express and
then there's you know other people that
are just kind of like open like kind of
like dealer's choice in a way and it's
like and then I invite whatever the
strongest purest thing is to come
through so I've been working really
really hard because big thing is about
being able to be as pure of a channel as
I can and understand that human and I
have ego and it's so understanding that
and accepting that to let it through
because it can get a little distorted if
we're not careful so there's a couple
things there maybe one of the first
things is that there's all this
different sort of signal that exists out
there you mentioned there's a Divine
Feminine there is a source there are
these different sort of things peace the
spirits of people of the past your own
higher self your own higher self
so all these signals exists so a process
of maybe slowing down closing your eyes
taking a deep breath feeling your body
feeling your heart and then maybe trying
to feel what exists outside of that and
then try and feel what exists in the
fabric of existence and then taking that
that feeling in through you is that
about right yes and I think another part
inviting it as being open to it
there were several years ago where I was
channeling those gibberish and I was
really scared I thought that I was
bringing in a message from someplace
that was trying to get through and it's
like really dark and stuff and then I'm
like oh my god I'm speaking this thing
and now it exists on this earth playing
like I felt very very scared of it I
didn't have people really showing me or
explaining things and it wasn't until
years later they found you know I'm you
know the higher your vibration is the
chances of something really really it's
just it's you know something darker more
nefarious coming in it's very in my
opinion very low but it's when we aren't
aware it's you know Ron and I earlier
before we started we're talking about
Ouija boards you know and I was like
they need to be burned like those are
true portals but when people aren't
aware of what they're actually opening
and unlocking it can it can create some
difficulties in your life so why don't
you maybe tap in to this sort of this
sort of what let's let's we will we'll
get to doing an actual an actual channel
yeah and maybe as we get to that I think
we maybe still need to just get a little
bit more description of this I think
with words I know this is ridiculous
trying to use words to describe feeling
and a subjective experience is very
difficult but okay
so there is a slowing down of the body
the slowing down of the mine they're
tapping into the body and then the
feeling of what exists outside of the
body in all that is all all that is
including what is in the third dimension
plus what is in the dimension outside of
that which we are still trying to
understand
with this very limited perception system
that we have and so we are able to get
to that point of understanding what is
outside of the perception system but it
takes it's a skill you were talking
about courage being something that has
to be trained over time like a muscle
well it's the same thing with this skill
has to be trained over time like a
muscle on a daily practice people that
meditate a lot in many times say that
they feel divine they feel divine when
they're really really deep in their
meditation and it is a whatever is
happening for them and their subjective
experience for me it was an incredible
amount of energy coming through my body
from the top through the mind through
the root through the bottom and it was
just incredible what I was doing so that
sort of feeling of what is the potential
that we can get to if we train that
muscle which we are definitely not
training children in the normal system
education system to be aware of we
barely even train emotional intelligence
let alone meditation and spirituality
and intuition
so was that did that hit a good amount
of the yeah mysticism yeah so a concept
they've shared before is that like
there's so many ways up the mountain
right so it can be through meditation
breath work you can be through yoga you
know whatever religion whatever it is up
to the top of the mountain of you know
our higher being our higher self you
know whatever whatever it is that we're
seeking there's a lot of ways up the
mountain for me I want the fastest most
efficient way and I want it to be with
people they've climbed up and down it
100 times and just did it yesterday so
for me in my experience doing how
working with Sampedro really got me up
or I don't know if I'm at the top but
got me up there much much I agree
the use of psychedelics use of them
practice of meditation transcending ego
that this is these have been massive
that's like the guy that you jumped with
on your skydive that had 35 years of
experience that that that's if this is
the whole surround yourself with people
that are smarter than you that are wiser
than you that are more successful that
are more self actualized than you and
just keep surrounding yourself with them
and keep learning from them and keep
building yourself around them and all of
a sudden you'll realize that you are
actually accelerating your climb up the
mountain much faster okay all right but
I think that's I think that was decent I
think maybe one more thing to talk about
before we get into the channel though is
what exists outside of the
three-dimensional reality sure you know
you may you know meditate or psychedelic
experience or whatever it may be that
that definitely transcends a
three-dimensional reality of like oh
look here's a glass and a cup and like
here's paper money to go buy food that I
spent my time to go earn so okay that
seems a little bit more you know mundane
in comparison to feeling like a divine
deity because you're meditating so what
exists outside of the 3 dimensional
reality that you've tapped into your
talked about you've talked about the
Divine Feminine you've also mentioned in
me before Rainbow realm and rainbow
children rainbow kids you know what yeah
teach us about this what are what are
these places what are these things what
are these entities what are soul
contracts what our soul families get get
us into that as well we have we can talk
forever right start us off with some
like cliff notes on those couple
okay so there's something called star
seeds so there are those of us are our
souls are not actually from here you
know there are people they're human
through and through and then there's
some who had souls that came from other
places people have heard of the Pleiades
so actually constellations different
planets different galaxies Sirius
Arcturians lots of different places like
that in terms of how do I know basically
it's like if you feel like you don't fit
in like if you're like I would I feel
like I was adopted I feel like I don't
belong in this group of people like like
you really really feel like an outsider
there is a very high chance that that's
because you are you're you're you're a
visitor you're well you're a light
worker so you're someone that's come in
from another dimension another place in
time to help us on earth because it's so
important that we assigned on this
planet then we make it through duality
and and we make it through this big
shift from patriarchy back to kind of a
union of divine masculine and feminine
on the planet so we all come here with
agreement so before we're born we are in
another dimension and you and I met and
we're like hey so we're gonna go do this
thing on earth they're like okay cool
awesome and then these other people were
like hey I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
break your heart awesome I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna really hurt you okay
awesome we're like we're all doing it
for love for us they have that lesson
here to get so where we're meant to be
to be doing the things we're here to do
so we have all of these contracts with
our parents like you know this only love
up there there is nothing else beyond
this there's only only love we are all
connected we're all one we're all unity
and then we agree to show up as
different elements and aspects so there
are some people that have had many many
lifetimes together not just on this
planet but in other dimensions and
existences that come together at this
time to do this thing right now
and so it's really let's let's let's go
let's go a little bit off that okay
so star seeds so there are different
star systems and stars and the galaxies
that are outside of our solar system
that have is are these physical beings
in the three-dimensional no these are
not they're they're outside of the 3d
okay so let's just let's let's take an
example so there is something outside of
the three-dimensional reality in another
galaxy and then that there is an
agreement between the souls the spirits
of what is in that area and they see
earth in the Milky Way galaxy and
they're like wow that place is really
important for us to go do light work at
that place and then they make an
agreement that okay
I'm gonna do this you're gonna do that
you want to do that okay cool and then
they make an agreement that they're
gonna go and seed themselves seed their
soul through a conscious human and that
way they can go and bring their light
work to earth when they look and they
see someone else that is also
potentially a light worker they can see
him you can potentially see if someone
is human you are saying there's a
difference between someone being just
human and someone being a light worker
or someone being a star seed so someone
could their soul could not have come
from a different galaxy their soul could
just be mele evolved on earth as well
yes there's a few distinctions I want to
make and one again I am NOT an authority
this is just my understanding of it okay
so I'm not telling preaching I'm just
this is my understanding so all of us
have souls and we all have soul families
so we are all part of a soul family it's
usually about 150 people then we've had
multiple lifetimes through in our past
lives and I think I told you this last
time that's the same thing as the Dunbar
number the amount of relationships that
you can hold with at least the human
cognitive cognitive ability which is
actually very interesting that that's
also the soul family number it's just
very interesting yeah so there's there's
people you're gonna come in contact with
and be like oh my god I just I feel like
you're like I know you I feel like we I
just I feel like this deeper connection
when you mean it's like as soon as you
see them as soon as you saw me you're
like there's something you know like you
just you know it and and then there's
the whole confusion of is like okay
where we are we like brother and sister
like what is this thing but you like you
feel like this deeper connection so
there's very many people I've met where
I'm like you feel like a mother to me
like I know you're younger than me but I
feel like you're my mom or like you know
all these different things so yes Thank
You Ronnie chances are when you hear
that
you're part of the soul family or feel
that when you feel that your private
little family so I don't know enough
about all the realms I'm still learning
but my understanding is that there are
people there are souls because beings
from other planets aren't really allowed
to descend here onto this earth so
instead they send the souls of those
beings through into our human bodies to
go and do this because if there was a
physical manifestation of them on earth
we would be like whoa what the hell yeah
and it's like we keep the balance of
like free will and free choice you know
and again we can't we show up forgetting
who we are so we that's one of the
conditions of
born on this earth is what we forget
where we're actually from so we go
through a process of remembering early
yeah an activation and you know all that
stuff and all the things lead up to it
and there are some people who might not
ever wake up so you and I may have had a
contract but let's say you you were like
on a totally different thing I didn't do
everything I was meant to do that's okay
because you know what there's gonna be
two other people they're gonna step in
and do the things that they needed that
we needed to accomplish together so
there's really like this sense of like
there's no way of getting it wrong it is
impossible to fail everything is
happening the way it's supposed to be
happening moment Simona you there is no
way for you to fail and that's only my
challenge prime creator that's like
they're supposed to be at bliss and at
peace in every single moment yeah and to
follow interest right into trust and
something that I channeled from prime
creator was like you think that they can
fail like you feel like you're a failure
and that is a fallacy there's no way
that you can fail you will never fail
and even if you're at the end of your
life it's like I did not leave live my
mind my life is doable this is the
definitely
will not leave you you will not fail
because we have so many contingencies in
place to make sure that everything that
needs to happen will still happen oh my
turn to the other cheeks
yeah so let's unpack let's unpack what
rocks like pushing a little bit here the
idea that you know everything's
happening the way it's supposed to be
happening moment to moment bliss peace
you know this was you know coming into
my mind that's well a little bit too is
that there is this you know there's a
dark there's some dark we feel the sort
of darkness in many ways and we see a
lot of suffering and we're like those
1.1 million refugees or O'Hagan's that
have been kicked out of Myanmar into
Bangladesh that's God
yeah that's God's will exactly forget
about a sea Krait well the good things
in your life and don't worry about it
they no attention to that man behind the
curtain but yes and it's free will a
free choice there is no intercession we
are here to play out this amazing
science experiment of what would happen
if everyone forgot everyone else in the
universe knows that we're all connected
we're all unity consciousness and there
most of them are copacetic yes there are
still some beings are like yeah screw
you I'm gonna go and do this other thing
there are those light and dark like it
has to exist there this is a planet of
duality that is why Earth is so
important one for the success and
benevolence of the universe as a whole
but to also for our old our own Souls
journey so a lot of souls will come here
knowing that this is a very very tough
path that they're gonna walk because I
forgotten Who I am I have free will and
free choice and I live in duality and
I'm dealing with light and dark black
and white extremes and nuances and I'm
constantly having to choose who what am
I going to choose am I going to choose a
higher or lower level of who I actually
am yeah that was that was a pretty good
breakdown right there I like I like that
breakdown okay so that that is taking
into a consideration something like the
1.1 million of them that are currently
in the refugee camps of Bangladesh are
there because there is a sort of
awakening lesson
earth is going through by understanding
these refugee crisis or the fight for
power the fight for money the fight for
wealth and for land and for territory
all these different things fight in
fighting in religion this is all some
sort of a lesson for us to better
understand but hold on there's a little
bit more here you are also impacting the
kind of like okay this is a tough soul
path on earth that you go and you make a
decision of okay I'm gonna let my soul
be born on earth I know it's gonna be
tough you're living in duality you're
living in light dark you're living at
forgetting where you came from and
having to remember that and you're
living and doing light work on the
planet okay so I like that that was an
interesting breakdown okay let's let's
this is hot right now like this is
feeling really hot like the subject you
know this is really good one oh I'm
liking it I know you like it spicy it's
like not a spice in here and spice it is
it's really hot the level is it's pretty
hot in here I like it okay so let's
let's go through this example now so
there is all that is and it's happening
right now and if we slow down enough we
can
feel
whatever comes in whatever comes up you
can hone that attention or that focus
you can hone it into something but you
can also let whatever come in mm-hmm
and so what would that so if you choose
to hom focus you can focus on my
actualization my love the love that
exists everywhere it said you can focus
on what you can also or a singular
spirit and let that spirit come through
so you can let anything come up so why
don't what do you feel right now do you
feel like wanting to do a focus or do
you feel like wanting to do it whatever
challenging for me so - two things came
up for me actually when we were as we've
been speaking and I need to check my
pendulum for just a second mm-hmm
okay so the two that I thought they're
like months not bringing so how about
what you're feeling
do you feel like you have a focus
question you'd like to ask or would you
like to to see what would like to come
and speak
there's a decent amount of me that wants
us to to channel that hot subject that
spicy subject that we were just on yeah
and I also feel like that could be a
whole episode over itself so then let's
do what's coming up well and I'm happy
to do that you know we can and then you
know like I'm happy to do that because I
know that there's also been things the
eve question and I just I've offered to
do late where's me what would what we're
doing is we're trying to make mysticism
relatable and and that in itself is not
a mysticism in 30 seconds okay okay
so okay so mother earth would love to
come in Gaia
Pachamama goes by a lot of names mm-hmm
she would love to come in
thank you so much for bringing this to
light and for being here thank you all
for this moment for me to to express my
love for all of humanity on this planet
and for you to understand that
everything that is on this earth has
been created for you for the thriving
for the abundance for the love the joy
for you as humans every single thing on
this planet can be used as a tool it can
be used to create horrible devices of
destruction of separation of of
termination of x.x extraction like all
these different ways and these tools can
also be created into things that bring
joy abundance prosperity healing
guidance aid support generosity and the
development and the benefit and the
progression of humanity this is what is
one of the most important things about
being on this earth as you mentioned
duality so too are all of these tools
they are up to you of how you choose to
use them a knife can be used to cut
Cutler cut up fruit and vegetables and
can be used to inflict harm on somebody
else a candle can be used to illuminate
new ideas pages papers whatever it is
that you need to see the guys along the
way and it can set a dwelling on fire so
it's so important to understand that
this is part of the thing of the free
will and free choice what is the before
the highest good and for you to
understand
and I am so tired and all I know how to
do is to give and Jessica Anna's channel
before where I all I know what to do is
to give all I know what to do is to give
you need wood to make furniture to build
homes take it you need wood like through
the Amazon if that's what it needs even
though it devastates me take it if you
want to reforest to replenish me please
do understand that everything does have
a result it doesn't have to be it you
can see it however way you want but as
Jessica Anne has realized as she looks
around on this planet there is not a
single thing that has been created
outside of me nothing has been created
outside of me and even with food I know
that so many of you deeply feel that you
need the nourishment of organic raw food
that are full of the vitamins and
benefits and yes I want all of that for
you for those for those who do not have
that access if you can understand that
even in the most processed foods still
underneath all of that process the
chemicals the ingredients still came
from me so if you can understand that
there is love in everything in
everything that you touch that you feel
that you ingest that you give that you
create that you build there is love at
the heart of all of it it becomes your
tool and what you choose to create with
that but everything in this essence is
love
and so to understand that that
everything has chosen to give its life
to you for your thriving every animal
every plant every speck of sand every
drop of water every molecule every
breath of air everything has been for
your thriving you are so loved you are
given everything to have an a beautiful
life and I love when people take their
feet off or take your shoes off of their
feet and plant it in this earth and feel
my radiance feel my vibration feel my my
love for them everything is connected
everything and I know there's so much
separation right now and that is where
your are in this world and yet more and
more of you in this extremeness that is
so outside of what is resonant and what
is true on what feels good and what
feels pure and what feels right to you
then it is calling that within you to
stand up to that which you might not
have done before you may not have done
that before
patriarchy has been around for thousands
of years devastation has been around for
thousands of years warfare has been done
I've been around for thousands of years
this is not a new story this has been
around and yet there are the people
especially the healers especially the
light workers that have been on this
earth for a lifetime's and have
sacrificed for all to get to this moment
in time where they can stand up they
have built their muscles over lifetimes
to be here and do the work that will
ascend us that will heal this planet and
so it is a calling to all of you that
feel that inside of you that I'm
to do more yes you are yes you are you
are meant to do more and for what it
looks like it's what brings you the most
joy what lights you up the most and
Jessica Anna is a reflection of that she
knows that she could tell every day for
the rest of her life and bring her joy
even in the face of friends turning
their back on her even in the face of
her family disagreeing with her if
that's their call if that's how they
feel even in the face of whatever she
will still continue to show up because
she is a brave heart and that is why she
is here and she is here to teach all of
you also if you choose how to be brave
this is not a time to be scared this is
not a time in a cower in fear this is
also not the time to be angry and
throwing and hurling anger out at that
which is causing the greatest contrast
in order for you to rise up and be why
you are here so have that grace and
maybe Tryon blessing that thing that you
face that proposition that you've seen
and you see it and how can it be how can
it exist it exists for you to wake up
and be that thing so that it is no
longer necessary that is an option that
you can try on that does not have to be
your truth but know that I have been
holding is sustaining and creating life
for much much longer than any of you
have been here and I have seen it I have
felt the blood the tears the agony the
suffering the pain I have absorbed all
of that all of it and I yet continue to
replenish and give anew and give more
birth and rebirth and cultivate and when
you work with me it changes
much faster believe that you are here
for a greater purpose believe that you
matter believe that even if you're just
a second in the expansion of time that
you can still be the brightest spark
that that second has ever been in
existence this is not about having ego
you can still have ego and still choose
to follow what is in your greatest heart
and your greatest soul's desire and
you'll know it because you feel like yes
you feel at peace and yet also excited
at the same time it's like it's just
this feeling of there's nope I know I'm
on the right track and I know I know
it's just feeling good I'm getting
closer it's Marco Polo like Jessica and
Ellen have talked about before it's the
Marco Polo you feel it you know what
you're getting closer have faith in that
what do you have to lose you can choose
the sit back and you can choose to allow
authority to control you and tell you
how life is meant to be and how you're
meant to show up and what you must
believe in or you can choose to tune in
word and look outward and pull that in
into you and move in that direction of
your life I bless you all please know
that every time you sit down whatever
food it is that you're looking at
whatever you're about to ingest know
that my love is in that and that will
sustain you know the power of that love
and allow it to fill up all the cells of
your pain
I love you
yes yes yes
that's good that's good right from Earth
right from Gaia from Pachamama yeah been
longer than been here longer than any of
you didn't hear through everything and
everything that is made on this earth
with love this for your thriving it's
good stuff just
that's good stuff thank you very much
thank you very much for that thanks for
introducing us to that and there's gonna
be a lot more to to unpack about being
able to tap into things like earth
energy it's happened to everything that
is this has been such a pleasure
unpacking mysticism well we have tons of
we've we have simulation questions but
we'll get to those I'm a different at a
different episode there's more to
channel and there's more to talk about
channeling more to talk about mysticism
or feel into this and into what this all
means why we're here why are we here
and Who am I remembering who you are
yeah the ultimate question of why we're
here yeah I think the greatest gift that
we can give another person and I know
your question my favorite question you
ask is what's the most beautiful thing
in the world well why don't you answer
that and then we'll yeah yeah I believe
it seen the soul in another person yeah
that's good I really I see you yeah I
don't think we've had that answer around
that's a good one like I see your soul
and that's what people want and one of
your felt seen recognized love that they
matter yeah but there's community that
cares about them yeah
thank you yeah what a pleasure
yeah it just just there's there's so
much still and this is just the tip and
of the iceberg and there's so much below
that will be a lot of fun to to continue
on packing and exploring together I want
to thank everyone for tuning in we
really appreciate it as you know there
was a comment with your thoughts below
we'd love to hear from you during the
community we have a public telegram the
link is in the bio as well join that
let's keep the conversation rolling
let's talk about this unpacking all of
its nuance also go create you know you
just watch this now there's things to go
build there's things to go manifest
manifesting your own soul purpose your
soul blueprint or whatever that may be
right draw video art go make also huge
thanks to Ron for producing and
directing much love to man Ron I think
from faith adding some spice as well
thank you just scan for coming on the
show and joining us we'll see you guys
soon
[Music]
you